in Hamburg hat die Stadt im Altonaer
Volkspark 48 neue Laternen aufgestellt
so soll eine beliebte jogging- und
spazierstrecke auch im Dunkeln sicher
genutzt werden können
stolze 400.000 Euro haben die Leuchten
gekostet allerdings hat die prima Idee
der Verwaltung ein ganz bösen Haken die
Dinger funktionieren nicht es fehlt der
Stromanschluss es bleibt stockdunkel
ja das ist ja totaler Quatsch besonders
jetzt wo es so früh dunkel wird wünscht
man sich schon dass hier ein bisschen
Licht ist
offensichtlich dann muss es halt
jemanden geben der Unsinn gemacht hat
ist wieder mal typisch Steuergelder
werden verbraucht und es wird mal wieder
gebaut und nicht vorher nachgedacht seit
vier Jahren wird die neue Beleuchtung im
Volkspark aufwendig geplant die Idee
auch wenn die Tage kürzer werden soll
man sicher den Hund Gassi führen oder
eine Runde joggen können und so stellt
das Bezirksamt Altona die Laternen auf
im Februar ist alles fertig nur Leuchten
tun die Lampen eben nicht denn der Stadt
eigene Energieversorger Stromnetz
Hamburg hat sein Kabel nur bis an den
Rand des Volksparks gelegt für den Park
sei man nicht zuständig im Park wiederum
hat das Bezirksamt Altona die Laternen
aufgestellt fürs Kabel verlegen fühlt
man sich jedoch nicht verantwortlich
absurdes Ergebnis die nagelneuen Lampen
bekommen keinen Strom der Park bleibt
dunkel weil ich gehört habe die haben
keine Kabel dann dachte ja ist ja cool
wahrscheinlich Solar oder so ne man muss
ja Männer gehen naja das ist mal wieder
so eine Provinz Posse das kein Strom
gelegt werden darf kann wie auch immer
und daher ist das natürlich irgendwie
verpulver das Geld ne das
Offensichtliche Absprache Desaster
versuchen sie im Bezirksamt schön zu
reden
ja es ist so dass es eben ganz intensive
Abstimmungsprozesse gibt manchmal ist
das in einer Stadt so dass man sehr sehr
lange Runden drehen muss und sehr viel
sprechen muss bis am Ende eigentlich
Entscheidungen auch fallen für den
endlosen Streit um Stromkabel haben die
Menschen gar kein Verständnis ja man
kann es nicht nachvollziehen es hört
sich an wie ein Schildbürgerstreich man
kann nicht verstehen warum die
aufgestellt werden und mich geprüft wird
ob ein Kabel ist oder was normalerweise
wenn man Lampen hinstellt wird da auch
vorher Leitung gelegt weil was würde ja
gar keinen Sinn ergeben nach dem ganzen
hin und her hat sich das Bezirksamt
Altona nun dazu durchgerungen die Kabel
selbst verlegen zu lassen wann das
passiert und die Lampen endlich leuchten
kann derzeit aber niemand sagen